お久しぶりです
はじめしゃちょーです
いやー 無事イタリア旅行から帰ってきました
なんて言うと思ったかバカヤロー
やっぱり来たよ
まあ前々からねもう情報は聞いてたよ
まあイタリアとても良い所でした
YouTubeの旅行言ったわけじゃないから
そんなに動画は撮れなかったですけど
写真は何枚か撮りましたよ
で 本当に良い所でした
パスタもうまいしピッツァもうまいし
町並みは綺麗だし
人も優しい
ただ！
まあぼったくりとかあるんだよな
やられちまった…
スリとか詐欺とかなんかぼったくりとか
もう前々から情報は入れてたわけなんですよ
日本とは違ってな?
外国はそういう人が多いんだよ
もう何か手伝うとすぐ
こうチップくれみたいな
お金くれみたいな
まあそういう奴らがたくさんいて
そのことはわかってたんだよ
だが俺はそう簡単にいかない
いやわかってたよ わかってたよ
ちゃんと調べたからね
だからもうある程度スリとかも
スリとかぼったくりとかも
全部もう
打ち勝とうしてする足だったんだけども
最終日はじめ氏は スペイン広場というね
イタリアにスペイン広場という
すごい有名なところがあるんだけど
あれねグローバーの休日のあの階段みたいなとこだね
まあそこで俺はねこうやっぱ最終日だったから
ちょっと浮かれてたわけよ
まあそれでもうスペイン広場で
気をつけなきゃいけないことっていうのは
もう本当にミサンガ売り
ミサンガをつけられるとお金が取られます
っていうことはもう前々から聞いてて
まあ大丈夫っしょと思って
こうふんふんってこう行ってたわけっすよ
そしたら
とある超いかつい男１人が
こうなんか話しかけてきて
でも話しかけて来るだけじゃもう
ミサンガ売りってわかんないじゃないですか
ミサンガ持ってたらミサンガ売だけどね
ミサンガ持ってなかったのに
こう来てこうハローみたいな
ハイハイみたいな
でなんか
うぇあ ゆー じゃぱん？ これあ？
みたいな
で あーじゃぱんじゃぱんって言ったら
おー ながともながともって言って
おーながともいぇすいぇすながともいぇいいぇい
みたいな こう
いぇいいぇいながともいぇいいぇいいぇい
みたいな感じになっちゃって
ちょっとこう楽しいわけじゃん
日本人知ってるイタリア人居るんだと思って
こうちょっとテンション上がっちゃってこう
いぇいいぇいいぇいイタリア最高いぇい
みんなかわいいいぇいいぇいいぇい
みたいな話をしてると
いきなりですよ
手首掴まれて
小指出されて
こういうねもうわけわかんない速度で
ミサンガつけられて
ミサンガつけられた瞬間ですよ
もう一人の男がやってきました
俺はその男に連れてかれ
ミサンガをきつく縛られ
ミサンガをきつく縛られて
まあ覚悟しましたよ僕も
まあもうお金はあげるぐらいの気持ちでもういいよ
と思ってこう言ったわけなんですけど
もぉ！
最初ねそうタダって言ったんだよ１人目の奴が
１人目のバカヤローがなんか
タダだよタダだよタダでミサンガつけたげるへー
みたいな いぇいいぇいありがといぇい
って感じで行ったらもう一人の男が
15ユーロとか言ってきて
15ユーロって聞いたらま大体ねぇまあ
1600円ぐらいだと思って
1700円ぐらいだと思って
うわーまあミサンガ1個1600円か～
うわーまあミサンガ1個1700円か～
いいよ～いいよ～うぇいおーけーいぇいいぇい
ってこう財布開けた瞬間
そこがねここが俺のミスだった
財布の中に結構お札を入れてて
何枚かはこう隠してあったんだけど
財布の中に結構入れちゃってて
もう財布を見せた瞬間
２人目のいかつい男が目つき変わって
のー のーのーとか言い出して
のー15 のー15 お札お札みたいな
お札お札とか言ってきて
で俺もさそんな甘いわけじゃ俺もねそんなね
甘くないわけよ
は？みたいな
高いっしょみたいな
お前高いっしょ
いぇい みたいな感じで言うと
なんか向こうも
のー！これがイタリア！これがイタリア！
とか言ってきて
俺も負けずに 高いっしょ！
ミサンガ高いっしょ
って言ったら向こうは
....No!
みたいにキレてきて
ちょっと俺これヤバイなと思ってこう
20ユーロ出すんすよ20ユーロ
2600円ぐらいだから2600こうやってこう
ぅぐぁぅ・・・
...いぇい！ってこう渡したら
No No Fifteen Fifteen
って言ってくるわけっすよ
フィフティーンっつったらもう50ユーロのことっすよ
まあ日本円でね6500円とかです
6500円こう渡すわけっすよ
そしたらなんか
一枚取られたら
なんかそいつは
Five Five
OneTwoThreeFour Five
って言ってくるんすよ
それどういうことかというと
50ユーロ5枚出せってことっす
250ユーロ
完全に終わった
ってならなかったんです俺は
俺はね負けたくなかったんだよ
絶対負けたくなかったから
俺はね 粘ったよ
いや それはおかしい
3万3500円ですよ
3万3500円をこんな変ななんかバカみたいな
ミサンガに3万3400円を渡すかって言う話っすよ
俺ねも完全に頭にきて
おいお前それはおかしいだろ
高いんだよってこう言ったら
財布もう俺開いてたから
もうそしたらもう目つき変わって
財布からバって
50ユーロ5枚もう盗られて
バイ…バイバイバイバイみたいな
って感じで250ユーロ盗られました
約3万4000円です
なんで…なんで250も盗るの…
3万4000円でしょ？
うわぁ゛ぁ゛ぁ゛ふっふっふっふ
って感じで実は250ユーロ
3万4000円分盗られました
でこう色々ネットで調べたらやっぱりスペイン広場は
日本人すごいミサンガに詐欺とられます
それもミサンガを売るとかじゃなくてこう
話し合いから入る
ミサンガ売っていうのわかりにくいタイプです
海外に行く人マジでものを売ってないような人にも
気をつけてください
完全に俺はね読めなかった
事前に調べてたけど読めなかった
結構いたんですよネットで
知恵袋とかツイッターとかも結構ミサンガをこう
つけられてお金とられたっていう人がいたんですけど
も
まあ
みんな大したことないな
みんなね所詮盗られても
10ユーロとか
20ユーロとか
そんな1000円とかでね
そんな2000円とかでね
そんなチマチマチマチマ言うもんじゃ無いよ
俺は250ユーロ持ってかれましたから
日本一です
ミサンガで詐欺られたランキング
多分俺がね今んとこ日本一だと思ってます
ネットを見る限りね
まあイタリアでも楽しかったんで別にいいんですよ
飯も美味しいし
人もねあんな人ばっかりじゃない
いい人もたくさんいた
ただほんの一部のせいだよ
ほんの一部の奴らのせいで
最悪な気分になったね
イタリアなめんなよ
無事帰ってこれたっていうお知らせと
外国行くときは本当に気をつけてください
俺はもう基本人を信じませんから
マジもう考えてみればわけわかんないミサンガに
3万4000円盗られる気持ちよ
その場で引きちぎったわ
もうパズドラ課金しよ
ッ もう
あのイタリア人 今度見つけたら
ブッころ